mark in North Carolina you're on the
bench Bureau show cohort mark hey what's
going on Ben how you doing today they
doing pretty well go for it sir actually
I wanted to ask with what Virginia is
attempting to pass through their their
legislature I know it passed on the one
side and now they're trying to get it
through where whatever happens with the
popular vote of the country would that's
where they would send their electoral
votes is that something that even if
they pass on both sides of the
Statehouse that they can actually push
through for the 2020 election with it
being you know a state affair affecting
what would be a national you know
federal level yes something that can
actually happen they can the electors
are chosen on the state level so it is
not it is not a federal requirement that
electors be chosen in any particular way
in fact theoretically you could have a
state that that through its electoral
vote decide to do it proportionally I
believe so I don't think there are
specific constitutional provisions on
point as to what a state itself can do
the assumption was always that a state
was going to to not make it proportional
because then that actually waters down
its impact right I mean if you were to
be Virginia I'm gonna hit somebody 150
to 45 your impact basically becomes a
net of maybe one electoral vote or
something so it's alright people sort of
assumed that that states would not do
this specifically because basically
Virginia is now saying that it doesn't
matter in the presidential election we
don't care what our people we don't care
what our people in Virginia think we're
just gonna go with the vast majority
hence California New York you know the
populous and then got to love the whole
voter ID oh we don't want to check IDs
it is the state of Virginia effectively
writing itself out of the of the
electoral college because again there
are only a couple scenarios here one is
that Virginia votes the same way as the
Electoral College in which case the in
which case there is no problem right if
they vote
Virginia votes the same ways the popular
vote in which case there really is no no
generalized problem or Virginia votes
differently than the popular vote in
which case Virginia is now overriding
the will of its own voters in order to
prop out whoever won the popular vote
which is a very weird thing to do and
defeats the purpose of the electoral
college
generally I guess it's a backwards way
of blue states trying to basically make
the Electoral College useless a
I guess they're basically said we don't
want the Electoral College to rule
anymore but that's one of the reasons
the founders never thought it would
happen they figured that states were
gonna be pretty zealous about their own
interests one of the areas in which the
founders vastly underestimated the
capacity of national parties to override
the interests of state parties mark
really appreciate your call the Blake
and Mississippi are on the bench Peter
Ostrow for Blake hey Ben I'm much like
you I was I was very anti-trump I just
thought he was a fool I thought he could
never win and it would have taken my
advice he would have lost and I think if
he would have taken your advice he would
have lost so how can you give him advice
now on what he definitely should and
should not be doing well I mean you know
first of all I refuse to suggest that if
he had taken my advice he would have
lost I I don't think that's right I
think that we could have done without
some of the more outrageous commentary
and kept with the good commentary right
my model all through the election was
very bad for him so more good Trump and
less bad form probably would have helped
him as far as giving Trump advice you
know like let's put it this way if he
has better instincts than I do then so
be it
but I think that all the people around
him are urging him basically the same
thing that I am and frankly I think that
any objective observer can see what he's
damaging himself including including
people who are very close to president
from you know you're not the best judge
in your own case always that is Trump
gonna listen to me no I mean Trump
doesn't let anybody but that's that and
that's his prerogative and I get it I
mean the man is is in excess of 70 years
old he's done nothing but win and so why
would he listen to anybody who is not
Donald Trump but I will say this the
when it comes to the presidency what got
you there is not necessarily what keeps
you there and this is why you've seen
presidents really shift tack I mean to
take the most obvious example Bill
Clinton right Bill Clinton enters office
with a plurality but not a majority of
the vote and he enters office on the
back of we're basically going to do
Hillary care which is Obama care and
then we are going to pass vast tax
increases and immediately he becomes
wildly unpopular and so he shifts
tactics and starts endorsing half of the
Republican plan so in 1996 he skunks Bob
Dole ain't an understanding kind of the
way that the tea leaves are moving
understanding you know that politics is
variable and that you have to shift as
times change is one of the elements of
being a good politician yeah
you want to be constant in your
principles but you also want to know
when you're making a mistake in shut up
and the thing about Blake the thing for
president Trump that's so irritating
just as a political observer
is that if you've got the good Trump
without the bad Trump the guy would be
unstoppable I mean I think we all felt
in the aftermath of the State of the
Union address like if we got this all
the time dude wins 55 to 60 percent of
the vote sweeps 46 states like we're
talking about him as a great president
of all time if you got Trump just one of
the Union dressed version if I may the
media though like they are so focused on
the controversy that I think that bad is
the new good like if you have a terrible
performance people will talk about it
for a week if you have a great
performance you might know buddy might
even talk about it
so trout just dominates it dominates the
media and they just they can't get away
from him so I think the media coverage
of President Trump is gonna happen no
matter what he is a fascinating
character and it is a fascinating to me
I do think that as I've said before if
the route if the election is a
referendum on Trump personally he's got
a problem if the referendum is on the
economy he wasn't if the referendum is
on Bernie Sanders he wins so the
referendum needs to be on anything but
him personally so anything he can do to
sort of minimize that which people find
off-putting is going to be is going to
be helpful to him he is the incumbent
president obviously I really appreciate
the call Blake we're gonna take more of
your calls in just one second but first
let us talk about why you should protect
yourself in 2020 okay the reality is
that digital security is just as
important as every other type of
security with which you are dealing if
you're dealing with with digital
security problems you need a VPN and you
need a VPN now you shouldn't leave your
front door unlocked or your car unlocked
you wouldn't leave your property
unprotected well why exactly would you
leave your internet activity unprotected
go check out express at VPN it's the
best VPN on the market why well first
expressvpn will mount log your data
watch out for those really cheap or free
VPNs they make money by selling your
data to ad companies expressvpn has
developed its own technology called
trusted server it makes it impossible
for their servers to log any of your
information another quality is speed
many of these VPNs will actually slow
your internet connection make it
difficult for you to get your work done
not expressvpn and finally expressvpn
super easy to set up you put it on your
computer click one button and you're
good to go
protect yourself with the same VPN I
trust and use and if it's good enough
for me it is certainly good enough for
everyone else use my link expressive VPN
comm slash Benson again
for three months for free on a one-year
package that's expressvpn calm /ban
visit exp ress VPN comm slash been to
one more expressvpn comm slash fan we're
taking your phone calls at eight five
five two three six thirty two twenty
eight jason and idaho you're on the
bench pure I go for Jason I've been
that's nice be on the show I'm a big fan
my question is about Bernie Sanders in
the media treating him I think pretty
unfairly lately he almost won Iowa he uh
he did win New Hampshire and yet most
mainstream media like refuses to
acknowledge it I saw a headline the
other day that talked about Budaj edge
and Warren and clover charts performance
and Bernie Sanders was not mentioned
covering New Hampshire so I want to know
if you think the media like legitimately
forgets about Bernie Sanders if you
think they like are trying to you know
intentionally mess him up in the
election like why do you think they just
refused to acknowledge that he's doing
at least as well as everybody thought
yeah I mean I think that that the
media's take on on Bernie is obviously
biased against burning obviously I think
it's it's hilarious that they weren't
biased against Bernie for for the forty
years when he was being an open
communist but now that he's actually I'm
first winning the nomination there's
something like oh wait a second and what
if Lee just pretend he's not the
front-runner I talked about this
yesterday with regard to MSNBC's Chuck
Todd was literally saying I'm not sure
why he's the front-runner well he's the
front-runner cuz he won the most votes
in Iowa and he won the most votes in New
Hampshire and presumably is gonna win
the most votes in Nevada and right now
he's probably gonna win South Carolina -
so like yes he is the front-runner
the media's refusal to acknowledge
Bernie is wish casting there they're
just attempting to wish into existence a
competitor to Bernie Sanders who stops
him from taking the nomination at this
point I have a hard time seeing who that
is
even if Bernie Sanders were to win a
plurality of the delegates and not a
majority which is a significant
possibility remember the Democrats
unlike the Republicans do not have
winner-take-all primaries
so if Bernie continues to win thirty
five percent of the vote all the way
through he ends up with a plurality of
Delegates not a majority of Delegates
but if he's the one who goes into the
convention with the most delegates
they're gonna give him the nomination so
the I do think just as the media are
biased against Republicans the media
have suddenly decided that they are
biased against Bernie Sanders
at least in so far as trying to kick the
nomination to somebody more palatable
like to them a people to judge or a name
in clove char although I think that if
it comes down to Sanders versus
Bloomberg I'll be curious to see if the
media actually continues with its
negative coverage of Bernie in in quite
the same way Jason it just seems to me
that since Donald Trump did so well and
essentially got his way to the
presidency through the Rust Belt using
his you know populist more populist
stances it seems to me like they would
want to support somebody who on the Left
would be a populist and try and try and
I guess recreate Donald Trump's path
well I think the problem they have is
that that bernie is so far to the left
he's so radical that they are correctly
fearful that burning will do much more
poorly in a general election than he's
been doing in the primary so far again
and by the way I don't want to be
completely unfair to the media it is a
big story that Bernie's vote vote share
dropped from 60 percent in 2016 in New
Hampshire down to 26% meaning that the
party is very split right now that that
does not mean that he's not the
front-runner however he is definitely
the front-runner Jason really appreciate
the call all righty coming up we're
taking more of your calls at eight five
five two three six 32:28 you're
listening to the Ben Shapiro show